bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
ce nouveau numéro de 7,8 débat le débat
sur le glyphosate se prolonge le
pesticide de monsanto s'est imposée dans
le débat public et divise depuis son
classement en 2015 par le centre
international de recherche sur le cancer
comme cancérogènes probables
la commission européenne vient de voter
le renouvellement de la licence de cet
herbicide controversé la france a voté
contre
emmanuel macron s'est ensuite prononcée
et à ramener cette autorisation de cinq
à trois ans sur le territoire français
alors faut-il interdire le glyphosate
purement et simplement le monde agricole
est il prêt quelles sont les
alternatives à cet herbicide
c'est le débat du jour avec nous ce soir
à nos voisins vous est agrégé en
sciences de la vie et de la terre et
coordinatrice de greenpeace versailles
et dominique dominique tristan pardon
directeur de la ferme expérimentale de
grignon et président de l'association
tels des yvelines bonsoir à tous les
deux bienvenue sur ce plateau dominique
tristan le glyphosate en france ces 9000
tonnes dans le monde huit cent mille
tonnes qu'est ce qui en fait l'herbicide
le plus utilisé au monde pourquoi alors
tant qu'il était réservé à monsanto dans
le domaine privé de son brevet il était
assez plus utilisé puisque assez cher
est vraiment ciblé sur des solutions des
besoins bien spécifiques on n'a pas
d'autre solution
depuis qu'il est tombé dans le domaine
public il était repris par d'autres
firmes concurrentes de monsanto est
banalisée et utilisé à larges allard
plus large échelle puisque c'est un
herbicide total qui amène un certain
nombre de solutions techniques à bas
coût sur le terrain sur le vote de la
commission européenne 18,7 à pour 9
contre dont la france finalement un
renouvellement pour cinq ans trois ans
en france
est ce que vous voyez ça comme un recul
politique ce renouvellement à nos
voisins nous ont plutôt un recul oui
puisque en fait
là on a voté pour un renouvellement sans
concession aucune
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas de vision de
réduction progressive en fait du
glyphosate donc on en reprend pour cinq
ans et au bout de cinq ans d'un revoter
pour savoir si on va encore rallonger
cette durée de vie alors qu'on aurait
préféré qui au moins en place un thé un
plan pour à différentes échelles arrivé
à au bout de cinq ans c'est vraiment
fini même on aurait aimé à moins de 5
ans d'ailleurs croiser vous partagez vos
photos vos sens en fait puisque en fait
monsieur macron a dit lorsque tu es élu
qu il remplirait pas des couches
administratives et réglementaires
supérieur à l'europe
et là sur un dossier concret bas il va à
l'inversé ce qu'il a dit puisque il
contredit l'europe en disant que ce sera
trois ans de cinq ans après je vais pas
vous dire que le glyphosate était bon
pour la santé
c'est un produit phyto et comme tous les
produits phyto il est mauvais je pense
qu'il faut plutôt travailler sur comment
on utilise dans quel cadre
plutôt que de vouloir l'interdire
bêtement moi j'ose dire bêtement en fait
puisque ça me semble pas la bonne
solution
vous comprenez 7 cette vision je
comprend enfin je partage le fait que en
fait c'est vraiment le la vision
agriculture de l'agriculture
conventionnelle d'aujourd'hui qu'il faut
qu'il faut revoir puisque nous on prône
pour un modèle totalement différent est
en fait le glyphosate a sa place dans le
modèle actuel qui s'intéresse en fait
les agriculteurs d'aujourd'hui ont été
habitués à utiliser ne savent pas
forcément les ne connaissent pas
forcément les techniques alternatives à
usage de ce pesticide et donc il faut
revoir le modèle et moi donner les
moyens justement aux agriculteurs de
d'aller vers cette transition vers un
modèle différent et donc c'est vraiment
un ces plus globalement il faut changer
les choses mais mais c'est vrai que du
coup pour nous le glyphosate n'a pas
sa place dans l'otan tout cas dans
l'agriculture que l'on désire mettre en
place alors sur sa sur le modèle
international envers venir dominique
tristan vous comprenez l'inquiétude des
agriculteurs qui ont pu manifester sur
les champs elysées et puis interpellé le
ministre justement sur ça après cette
annonce oui bien sûr en fait des
solutions techniques
contrairement à ce que dit madame on en
connaît beaucoup au niveau du monde à
l'école le tout et qu'on est dans un
marché mondialisé de matières premières
agricoles et qu'on ne peut pas armes
égales avec nos compétiteurs
ceci dit je pense que dans 90% des cas
c'est un chiffre pas puis mais je pense
que c'est l'heure de grandeur
c'est essentiellement le bac ou du
glyphosate qui fait qu'on utilise dans
des cas où on ne peut techniquement
assez facilement et à un coût un surcoût
modéré trouver une alternative est resté
quelque part dans la course dans la
course et donc c'est plus le coût que
peut-être la facilité il est la facilité
et la facilité d'usagé effectivement un
camp vous quand vous paierez pulvérisé
avec un bon équipement du type osanloo
fait énormément de surface la même
journée quand il faut travailler le sol
c'est totalement différent vous
consommez beaucoup plus de kew donc
aussi question derrière deux
compartiments environnementaux soit on a
un impact via le glyphosate
soit on a un impact sur le changement
climatique via le travail du sol via la
consommation de fuel etc
donc c'est des vases communicants et
faut pas avoir que qui est glyphosate
est bon et mauvais et ce qui n'est pas
d'hydrater bon c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça et agrément je suis
bien placé pour le savoir ce qu'on
mesure beaucoup de choses après sur le
sujet glyphosate je pense que voilà le
débat il est sur les 10 % de cas où
techniquement c'est très compliqué de se
passer du glyphosate dans un cadre voilà
de marché
mondialisé où on se tire une balle dans
le pied à l'interdire clermont est donc
moi a dit personnages sont en faveur
d'une régulation de l'utilisation dans
des cadres bien particulier où on sait
que si on ne l'a pas ça va être
compliqué plutôt que de se dire on
interdit de manière totale et brutale
encore une fois quand nos compétiteurs
auront accès aux bureaux that et à
d'autres technologies va pas parler
aujourd'hui que nous ne peut pas
utiliser un autre voisin une régulation
plutôt qu'une interdiction
bah c'est ce que enfin nous on parle
enfin régulation nous on voudrait
pouvoir l'éviter complètement parce que
pour l'environnement c'est une pollution
ça c'est certifié sur la santé il ya des
débats bien que celui ci soit classé
quand même cancérogène probable mais
pour l'environnement en général le
glyphosate sait il est utilisé avec des
adjuvants puisque sinon il est
inefficace et celle du vin sont
extrêmement polluant donc pour surfer
pour les sols pour les rivières et donc
au nom des impôts est aussi sur les sur
les animaux sur l'environnement en
général
donc faudrait plutôt une interdiction
par contre oui on va pas du jourdain
dire on l'interdît
certes il va falloir une période de
transferts transition pour les
agriculteurs qui l'utilisaient qui
peut-être que le monde agricole connaît
les techniques mais eux ne les ont
jamais appliquée donc pour leur
apprendre déjà il va falloir des
formations peut être et c'est un
changement de point de vue aussi qui va
être un peu peut-être moins se mettre en
place
dominique christian sur les adjuvants je
vois la nagra des adjuvants
effectivement il y avait du vent dans
tous les produits phytosanitaires pour
le coup là le glyphosate c'est un
produit relativement simple et les ailes
du vent qu'on peut remettre en plus les
as du ventre est très basique qui ma
connaissance non pas d'action spécifique
sur l'environnement sap a dû chef
d'ammonium ou l'huile végétale et je
vois pas bien les phases de risque il ya
sur ces atouts hier encore il ya un des
mines des formules qui a été interdite
en france justement parce que l été avec
alors j'ai plus le nom de la du vent
parce que ça vous déformez le
ben je suis pas spécialiste mix mais
qu'elle était interdit enfin le
glyphosate associé à cet adjuvant là on
était interdite en france donc c'est
bien qu' il ya des soucis des risques
qui sont déjà connus en tout cas pour le
coup le principe de précaution a été
appliqué pour cet exemple là mais on ne
l'appliquent pas pour le la molécule de
glyphosate plus largement
alors sur l'aspect international
justement c'est pas un peu hypocrite de
remettre en question les usages du
glyphosate seulement là on est dans ce
débat en ce moment sans s'interroger en
même temps sur l' usage de l'agriculture
chimique au niveau international ben
nous on est sur un modèle international
et on essaie d'en fin greenpeace est une
organisation internationale et donc on
le modèle d'agriculture qu'on veut on
aimerait le même tout toute échelle on
est donc on se bat dans différents pays
pour mettre en place une agriculture
plus vertueuse dans différents pays
il se trouve qu'en france on est un des
gros consommateur de pesticides et donc
notamment de glyphosate et donc on a une
campagne particulièrement actif sur les
pesticides en france parce qu'on est un
gros consommateur ramené à la production
ne suis pas du tout sûr qu'on soit un
gros consommateur de diplomates mais je
n'ai pas les chiffres ne vais pas me
lancer sur le sueur sur une pente
glissante que je ne ferais pas jusqu'au
bout mais intuitivement je pense qu'on
est bien meilleur que les états unis que
le brésil l'argentine c'est plus
discutable
après le débat de fond sur l'agriculture
au niveau mondial il est quelque part
dans le consommateur à travers ces actes
d'achat comment on pourra orienter notre
production aussi aujourd'hui il ya un
marché bien identifiés qui avec le
marché bio qui au passage n'est pas
forcément que des produits français qui
pose des questions aussi derrière et
puis après on a tout le reste je dirais
certes certains labels label rouge et
caetera et ça reste quand même les
marchés plutôt de niche
le gros de la consommation qu'on le
veuille ou non il est quand même sur des
produits
les produits alimentaires transformés et
les industriels dans des logiques
économiques vont acheter des matières
premières les moins chers possibles et
on est sur ce marché mondial et tant
qu'on n'aura pas une reconnaissance des
vertus environnementales techniques
sociales de la culture française on
restera sur un marché concurrentiel et
la profession de l'école ce sera
toujours bloqués sur des contraintes
appliquées au niveau d'exportations
agricoles françaises que ses
compétiteurs européens ou pays tiers
n'ont pas et je pense que le débat il
est là on fait aujourd'hui
oui c'est certain que on aura toujours
des concurrents sont à dire ils peuvent
pas vraiment en faveur de la victime
française par contre je suis pas
d'accord pour dire qu'il ya un seul
marché et qui a tendance à toujours tout
ramener à la baisse
il ya vraiment un marché de la
nourriture de qualité qui existe
maintenant france et qu'ils développent
les hyades et des associations
d'agriculteurs bio qui s'en sort très
bien sans glyphosate c'est une
agriculture de pointe une agriculture de
qualité et une agriculture de rendement
donc à partir de là c'est un modèle
qu'on peut essayer d'étendre un peu plus
d'agriculteurs il ya un autre point sur
lequel voulait revenir sur le glyphosate
c'est que ben nous on est aussi contre
l'utilisation des ogm est aujourd'hui
c'est trois quarts des ogm qui sont
faits dans le monde qui sont résistantes
au glyphosate donc qui ont produit des
ogm pour qu'ils résistent à cet
herbicide de manière à ce qu'on puisse
répondre beaucoup plus d'herbicide sur
les champs donc ça fait déjà augmente
forcément les tonnages de glyphosate qui
sont répandues sur les singes sur les
champs et avec les problèmes
environnementaux et sanitaires du cou
qui en résulte et la boucle aussi de
rachat forcément donc problème financier
et social on va dire de ce cercle
vicieux
dominique tristan comment est-ce qu'on
aide un petit agriculteur
pour passer à cette transition justement
l'aider
est ce qu'on lui donne plus de temps est
ce que c'est une question de budget je
crois que surtout faux pas déjà opposé
bio et non bio parce qu'au sein d'un
système congé il ya plein de diversité
et il ya plein de l'agriculteur qui
utilisent aujourd'hui très très peu de
glyphosate voire pas du tout y compris à
côté de moi non là j'en connais qui
travaillent avec des solutions sont 110
x date c'est le premier point des gens
donc il ya des solutions techniques qui
existent pour en utiliser très peu après
la transition
elle se fera via le marché d'une part et
via la capacité de chaque acteur à
trouver des solutions dans son cas de
contrainte à lui son cas de contrainte
c'est quoi c'est son type de sol sont le
type de culture et sa capacité
financière à prendre des risques parce
que dès qu'on change de système
forcément on est moins à l'aise et
typiquement là sur le cas du glyphosate
la banalisation du produit a fait que
certains ont développé des systèmes de
production qui repose très clairement
sur l'exception du glyphosate et
l'enlever du jour au lendemain ça change
totalement le projet d'entreprise
et ça on importe quel industriel vous
l'enlever le point clé dont la
technologie au départ forcément il est
dans une situation très compliquée à un
mot de conclusion
alors en fin de set est si on a été
quand même relativement déçu par par la
décision des cinq ans pour
l'autorisation renouvellement du clip
fausses at il se trouve que sur
plusieurs points nous on sera on
continuera et on sera toujours contre le
filet les effets sur la santé
c'est une chose mais il ya aussi tout ce
qui est fait du coup sûr sur
l'environnement et plus généralement les
conditions sociales des agriculteurs qui
sont plutôt du cou qui doivent racheter
tous les ans cet herbicide
merci à tous les deux merci d'avoir
participé à cette émission fin du set 8
débat ce soir consacrée au glyphosate
l'émission est à revoir son notre site
internet a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux
bonne soirée à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]